yeah welcome to this video playing
Barracuda slightly differently spouts
than usual from UK play the Scotch for
Knights let's play simple opening all
right gap you're not going to change
with the deep one okay maybe it was
confused somehow with the move order so
so yeah just castles or d5 now yeah C
takes d5 castles castles and then aged
three editors chronic smooth of course
it's not the kind of move that can scalp
like terribly but the the main virtue of
the smoothness that you can easily
develop your pieces and it's um it's
rather solid sometimes you can initiate
some play against the pawns c6 and c5
with Knight a four this is one one point
that's just complete development
yeah maybe queen d4 Knight f4 some
freaking night a for now how it's going
to play that maybe maybe this is okay 24
coming
should I go before no or queen or
Seaforth okay there are some some ideas
see force also one of them before is
probably playing a 500 but it looks it
looks a bit a bit more comfortable for
white even even after a five a five I
just go away three yeah should I change
Queens I'm not sure or Queenie home just
Queen diva
yeah I don't think that the exchange
helps me too much
hey maybe can play a 583 and then kun a
7 but ok what can you do hmm oh this is
curious why isn't he playing a 5 and
should i prevented this second question
but I can't play a flag Bishop to a 6 cm
yeah let's do that prevent the a poem
from moving move like a bishop at 5 it's
not there helping him really I can even
take a play Bishop d7
yeah but you cannot you cannot play
whoops c8 no or anything i can i can
play C 5 C 5 Oh No attacking the bishop
mmm
do I have Queen d3 still
yeah maybe queen d3 isto god this is
really heartbreaking you're out playing
completely like itself is really cannot
do anything and overlooking this simple
trick here gives black a good game now
what the howl of how to defend this no
one is really crap anyway
of course the night is no ridiculous on
a forum it was a great piece before just
controlling the whole Queen side and now
it is ridiculous
yeah it's just bad what can you do
yeah when he's playing this like no
comment could just have taken b3 and I
basically resign and this isn't even so
p.m. it's technically I'm at least not a
lot easy okay yeah come on take this
can I take it now or my nap in then yeah
I am in a pen I'm tending to what yeah
he's not even trying to win so just
trying to win on time yeah I don't know
what he was doing was just winning and
yeah c3 c3 this is heartbreaking
yeah it's not like I'm winning or
anything but black is basically our
plate here I reached everything that I
can hope for in this this kind of
position I have him located oops on the
light squares and he cannot cannot do
much here it's just very one-sided
I can also just just do this here all
with the Queen even I don't know this is
some this is very one-sided he's got the
spawns fixed on light squares that my
engine here only have stock fish on you
at the mood this has is this a slightly
better for blackest it's just a complete
joke I mean everyone up did program the
evaluation function of this like can
never be better here no way but okay
overlooking c5 is just la just terrible
yeah thanks for watching